Another day,
another Unisa edition
my loves guys,
join those telegram groups like join, join, join,
join those telegram groups guys
um, people in those telegram groups guys,
they were going
they are going to help you
they're going to help you
if you don't understand something
people also like
people can remind you that they've been
changes that have been made on the search and module
and also maybe if Unisa is updating something
people they sent textbooks,
postpation papers
and like literally guys
Telegram group is really
convenient if you're an Unisa student
so please do make sure that you
join those Telegram groups guys,
please please go now
download that Telegram
if you want to join the Telegram groups
you can just literally go on the internet and say
Unisa Telegram groups
and then you click on the
on the link and then on the link
you're going to type your module code
and then it's going to refer you to the Telegram group
and then you're going to join from there on guys,
you are going to like.